There you go. It's 2:30, so we'll get started.
Good afternoon, everyone. Thank you all for joining us today in the Digital
Pathology Mini Symposium at ACR.
My name is Pallavi Tiwari. I'm an associate professor at the University of
Wisconsin-Madison in the Departments of Radiology, Biomedical Engineering, and
Biomedical Informatics.
My research focuses on developing AI and machine learning approaches
in the context of radiology, pathology, multimodal
AI, in the context of different applications, different cancer applications,
and neurological disorders. And I have with me Dr.
Satish Viswanath. Do you want to go ahead and introduce yourself?
Sure. Hi, everyone. Good afternoon. I'm Satish Viswanath.
I'm an associate professor of Pediatrics and Biomedical Engineering at
Emory University. My research also focuses on artificial
intelligence, radiomics, deep learning,
pathomics for different oncological applications across both
adult as well as pediatric cancers.
So very happy to have everyone here.
Yeah, we have seven presentations today
spanning multiple different applications around prognosis and
prediction for different types of cancers.
So the order of business is that we'll have our speakers, we'll call them
out. Everyone has 10 minutes for presentation and five minutes for
questions, and then towards the end, we'll have 10 minutes for general
discussion of the presentations that we
hear about today. So with that, we will get started with the
first presentation
presented by
Yujie Zhao, and the title of the presentation is
"Elucidating Broad Cell-Cell Interactions
via 3D Super Cell Graphs for Prostate Cancer Risk
Stratification."
It's not here.
It starts.
Oh, there it starts.
Oh, here you go.
Should I start?
Yeah, go ahead.
Yes, go ahead.
Hello, everyone. My name is Yujie Zhao, and I'm
a PhD student at the University of Washington.
My PI, Dr. Johnson Liu, and my collaborator,
Larry Chu, are co-founders of Albenglo Bioscience.
So to begin with,
let's start with the 2D pathology.
Pathology plays a central role in disease diagnosis and
treatment planning across many different disease types and
has proven to be highly effective in clinical practice.
And here is showing a general pipeline of how we do
the conventional 2D pathology. We fix, dehydrate,
embed the tissues, and then section the tissues into thin
sections and stain them with hematoxylin and eosin, and
finally generate the histopathological images for pathologists
to review.
Despite its success, there are a few limitations.
First, it's destructive. As we section the tissues, we
are disrupting the spatial continuity of the depths.
And secondly, it's limited sampling, as we're usually
only analyzing a small number of the sections from the whole
volume. And thirdly, it only provides 2D view.
And for example, for convoluted structure,
some convoluted structures may appear as discrete objects on a
2D plane. And secondly,
in a 2D plane, it's not able to capture
the full spatial organization or heterogeneity across different
tissue regions.
So basically, when we view on 2D, it's an arbitrary
cross-section, and you are missing the information above and below that
section. And finally, the sparse or rare objects may be
entirely missed when we view on a 2D plane.
So to address these limitations, our group has developed this
non-destructive, rapid slide-free 3D
pathology over the past decades.
Similar to the conventional 2D pathology, we fix and stain the tissue,
but instead of sectioning it, we optically clear the tissue
and image them using a 3D microscope.
So this workflow provides three main advantages as it's
non-destructive, comprehensive sampling, because we are
capturing essentially 100% of the tissue, and it
provides a 3D view.
And the core technology behind it is called open-top light
sheet microscope. Just to briefly introduce the technology,
OTLS is a 3D microscope platform capable of
imaging large clinical specimen.
And the optical clear tissue will sit on top of this
transparent sample holder, and the light will travel from below
at 45 degree to capture the 3D images.
And here is a video of prostate biopsy imaged
with OTLS.
Given the advantage of our data set, in this study, we are going
to focus on cell interactions. Cell interactions are
increasingly recognized as important contributors to patient
outcomes across many cancer types.
Here are showing two different panels with the same cell
type compositions, and the study finds that the mixing pattern
of different cell types are associated with good
prognosis. So the core idea here is that not
only the cell type composition matters, but also their spatial
organization matters.So
using our 3D dataset, we want to
evaluate whether the 3D cell-cell interactions are
prognostic in prostate cancer.
So graphs are a simple way to model the cell-cell
interactions, where we treat
cells as nodes and interactions as edges.
However, extending this to
3D introduces challenges. We have 10X
more cells and 100 times more interactions,
which lead to two main problems. First, it's computationally
expensive, and second, it has a higher risk for
overfitting, especially when we have limited patient samples.
And looking to biology, we think cells
work collectively to exert meaningful biological functions.
So one potential solution to address the
data skill challenge is to reduce the data size by grouping
cells that are similar. So we
group cells that are phenotypically similar and
spatially adjacent cells into what we call super cells,
and here is the illustration.
Based on this general concept, we developed Skell 3D, a
super cell graph analysis framework for a large 3D
pathology dataset.
For each 3D dataset, we divided them into different
chunks, which allows us to do parallelized
processing.
And for each chunk, we first do nuclei segmentation to
localize the cell, and then we extract the nuclear
morphological features.
And then we form the super cells by grouping spatially
close and morphologically similar cells into super cells, and
each super cell is represented by the main feature of its constituent
nuclei.
And then based on the morphology, the super cell are clustered
into different cell types, and based on that, we form the
super cell graphs. From the graphs, we extract features that
describe the interactions between different subtypes.
And finally, we aggregate the graph-derived feature
into patient-level feature to
evaluate their prognostic performance.
And here is a 3D spatial view of the pipeline.
So we start with the nuclear segmentation,
and then we form the super cells,
and then we do super cell subtyping, and then finally,
we form the super cell graphs.
So to evaluate the prognostic value of Skell
3D, we used a specimen from 76 patients with
known five-year biochemical recurrence outcomes.
Prior studies have shown that nuclear morphology and glandular
morphology are prognostic, which we use as the baseline
here.
And here we show that Skell 3D achieved a higher AUC
for five-year BCR prediction, and similarly
for survival analysis, we also see a similar
trend.
So with the same dataset and evaluation method, we next tested
whether integrating Skell 3D with 3D morphology
further improves the prognostic performance.
So using only 3D morphology achieves an AUC of
0.68, and when
integrating with Skell 3D features,
the AUC increased to 0.8.
And for the survival analysis, we also showed a similar gain,
with the C-index rising from 0.64 to
0.61.
So now we show that the Skell 3D pipeline can extract
prognostic features, but one concern is that compared to the
standard cell level graphs, it may lose its biological
detail and reduce the predictive power.
So to address this, we compared the Skell 3D with a
standard cell level graph and using the identical
downstream evaluation method and processing steps.
We evaluated on two metrics. The first is
performance, was evaluated by the AUC for
five-year BCR prediction. And for
efficiency, was evaluated by computation time.
So on the result, we can see that the super cell achieved a
higher AUC, and in terms of
efficiency, it reduces the computation time by around
25-fold.
So
there are two possible explanations for the increased performance.
One possible explanation is
that by reducing the data complexity, we reduce the risk of
overfitting, especially in the small cohort settings.
And the second hypothesis is that
when we grouping cells into super cells, it may help
reduce the noise from staining
variation, imaging variation, or nuclear segmentation or
feature extraction, which allows us to have a more stable
representation. So to briefly summarize
the whole study is we
propose a super cell level framework for efficiently model cell
interactions in large-scale 3D dataset.
And we show that this approach not only
captures meaningful prognostic information but also
outperforms standard cell level graphs while being
much more computationally efficient.And I would like to
acknowledge all my lab members and collaborators for
their help on this project, and I'm happy to take any
questions if you have.
Thanks, Yujie. Do we have any questions?
There's a mic back there if you want to.
That was actually an excellent presentation. So I just had a quick question.
So was there any ablation study done to determine how many
cells were being considered for the supercell?
So that if there's a number between K is equal to three to
50, was there a way to evaluate the
performance based on the number of supercells?
Yes. I do have extra slides if I can go back to my
slide. Is that possible?
Are you able to?
No. Oh, okay.
Yes, we did ablation study about the--
Let me just quickly go to the slide I have.
So here is two parameters defining.
So first is the neighboring cells threshold, which basically defining
how large is the supercell, and the next parameter is
the supercell interaction distance.
So we do have the ablation study for neighboring cells
threshold. We did 10 to 30 micron, and for
interaction distance, we did 10 to 60 micron.
And based on this ablation study, we found that 15
micron is optimized for neighboring cells threshold
and 20 micron is for interaction distance.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Right. I have a question about comparison
with 2D.
Mm-hmm.
So I know the whole hypothesis is that 3D would be more
prognostic.
Yeah.
I wonder if you've compared it with just sort of baseline H&E slides to see how
good the results are.
Yes. Thank you for the question.
We didn't do a 2D slides, but we
did two tests
how the different portion of the data we use
affect the final predictive performance.
So we find that
if we use 100% of the tissue, the full
spatial contacts will maximize the predictive
performance, while you can see over here, 10% to 50% is
a much lower AUC.
So 10% here would be analogous to a 2D section?
10% was around
a few more slides than 2D.
Mm-hmm.
Like three or four slides.
Okay.
Yeah.
The other question was, so you
have the cell detection, then you're going to supercells, then you're going
from supercells, you're going to neighborhoods, and so on and forth.
So it's kind of this-- You
have data to back up some of the methodological choices, but what we were
wondering was how much-- Is there a way to kind of assess the error
propagation that might happen as you go from one stage to the next,
right? Because the supercells are dependent on the cells-
Yes
... and so on and forth. So is there a way to assess what the error propagation
might be as you go from cells to supercells to your final prediction?
So we actually did one other ablation study.
I don't have the results over here, but we do--
Just to repeat your question, are you trying to say
when we from cells choose
supercells, we
introduce the noise or the errors introduced within-
Yeah
... the steps?
Yeah.
Yeah. So we actually did a
human introduced-- We added human introduced
Gaussian noise. Basically, it's a simulated noise on the cell level, and we
performed identical
downstream steps. And we show that actually, the supercell
level is more robust to noise-
Okay
... based on their performance. But I don't have the results shown.
That's okay.
And one more final question I have is about your validation.
So it seems that your results are from leave-one-out cross-validation.
Is that correct?
Yes.
My question is,
have you considered independent validation?
Because I think the values were not as high.
So I'm just curious what your thoughts are on that.
Yeah. Thank you for the question. I think this is one
of the limitations in this study as we don't have
independent cohort. But I think this will be a
future work to validate the pipeline.
Okay. Great.
If there are no other questions, we thank the speaker again.
Thank you.
Right.
The next presentation is by Sumana Biswas.
Title of her presentation is "AI-Driven Spatial Analysis of
1,100 Head and Neck Squamous Cell Carcinoma Patients' H&E
Slides Uncovers Three Tumor Subtypes with Markedly Distinct Tumor
Microenvironments and Survival Patterns."
Hi.
Good afternoon, all. My name is Sumana Biswas.
I'm a postdoc fellow in Cedars-Sinai Medical Center.
I will present our work of using the deep
learning technique to predict the spatial transcriptomics from
histopathology images in head and neck cancer, and what we
found across 1,400 patients.
So this is the updated result, I would say.
So I don't have any financial relationship to disclose.
This is the content of my today's presentation.
So in every year
across the world, around
900,000 patients are told that they have head and neck
cancer.And in advanced stages, only half of them will
survive five years.
Now, this is not for lack of trying.
So the clinicians are skilled. The treatment exists.
However, we often take the
decision without knowing the right information about the tumor
microenvironment, the ecosystem of the cancer cell, which
hold all the information regarding the
patient's survival, who would relapse and who would not.
Now, the spatial transcriptomic technology can map those
ecosystem beautifully.
However, it costed around thousands of dollar per sample,
require fresh tissue, and we can apply
this maybe on dozens of patients, not on the thousands of patients who
needed it.
So in the meanwhile, in the biobank across the world,
sitting behind is the pathology slides from the millions of
patients. They are H&E stained, archived, and untapped.
So we asked, what if we could use the deep learning
model
to see those images and read out the spatial transcriptomics of
tumor microenvironment.
So doing this, we asked two research question.
Can these H&E-informed spatial transcriptomics
capture the real biology of head and neck cancer?
Because if the answer is yes, then we have something extraordinary,
a window into the tumor without any extra cost.
The second question is that if we could do so, can this be relevant
to the clinical applications? Can this informed spatial feature
stratify the prognoses and the therapy response at large cohort
scale?
To answer these questions, we come up with our model,
H&E-informed spatial transcriptomics for biomarker discovery
in head and neck cancer.
The input to the model is the H&E slide, and the output is the
predicted spatial transcriptomics at the spot level.
We train the model on 10 patient data and
cross-validated across two external dataset.
And when it's done, we've applied it for the clinical application
for treatment response and survival analysis
on around 1,400 plus patients, only H&E
images, no sequencing.
This is the slide which I love to showing people.
The first column is the H&E slide, the second
column is the measured EGFR spatial transcriptomics,
and the third column is the highest predicted.
As you can see, the hotspot and the cold spot maps beautifully.
So the model is not remembering, it actually capturing the real
biology from the morphology.
We can see the similar pattern in other two gene expression,
MMP2 and ACTA2, which is very much relevant to
head and neck cancer. In addition to that, we also quantitatively
measure how many genes we can robustly predict across the
cross-validation and the external validation.
We found around 2,800 genes, and these 2,000
genes is actually capturing the real biology of the head and neck cancer
when you perform the gene set enrichment analysis using the 50
cancer hallmark.
Now what it get more exciting. Once we
have this model, we apply the model on the large cohort like TCGA head and
neck cancer. It consists of around 445 patients.
What we did is that we have the spatial data, now we cluster those data,
and we identified 11 distinct spatial cluster.
The spatial cluster abundance is vary between the patient across the
cohorts, and we hypothesize that this
variation could be the
reason for the different clinical outcome.
So we represent each of these patient by this 11 spatial
cluster and do the hierarchical clustering,
wholly unsupervised. And what we found is very interesting.
We found two meta cluster, which we call it as spatiotype.
And when we perform the gene set enrichment analysis on these two spatial
cluster, we found that one cluster is enriched with
immune-related pathways. We call it as immune activated
spatiotypes, and another cluster is enriched
for proliferative metabolic, and we see that the immune-related gene
has given up. So we call it as immune exhausted like.
Now here is the critical point. Now we have these two spatiotype.
Now we can represent each of these 445 patients
by one of these spatiotypes. And we wanted to check whether this
has any clinical relevance or not.
So what we did is that we did the survival analysis
on these patients and plot the Kaplan-Meier.
And what we found is that the immune exhausted like spatiotypes
have worse survival than a immune
activated type. We found a similar pattern in other two
survival endpoint, progression-free survival and the disease
specific survival. Even with the adjusting for the age and stage, it became
significant.
We also try to find out whether it is applicable for the HPV
negative patients or not. We found a similar pattern.
We
could not perform the same analysis for the HPV positive because of the
small sample size. However, we wanted to check whether this
spatial cluster or the spatiotype can be recapitulated in
other external large cohorts or not.
So we utilize two dataset, one publicly available dataset named
Hancock. It comes with 700 patients data
with all the survival information.
And what we found is that for overall survival,
for all the patient, for HPV negative and HPV positive, the
pattern is recapitulated. It also recapitulated in
the recurrence-free survivalWe also performed a
similar analysis on another cohort from Taiwan.
It has around 231 patients, and for the recurrence-free
survival, we see the similar pattern.
The immune exhausted has the worst survival than the immune
activated. So we have three cohorts, three continent,
but the same story. So we could conclude that the spatial
type as the strongest predictor for the survival in head and
neck cancer.
But wait, this is
just the beginning.
We also wanted to check whether we can use the spatial cluster to predict
the treatment response before beginning the
therapy as well.
So we took the subset of patient
from the TCGA. It consists of the response data.
So the similar analogy we considered that we
represent each of these patient by this 11 spatial cluster and model
it. And we found that our spatial cluster-based model
have higher differentiating power with AUC of
0.74 and higher odd ratio like five.
In addition to that, we also wanted to check if we can do
this for different therapy response.
So we have another cohorts for immunotherapy.
It consists of around 94 patients, and we see that the
similar pattern that our spatial cluster-based model outperform than
the other biomarkers.
So
from this, we can conclude that without any cost,
what we have is the slide. With that slide, we can
do everything.
In summary, I want to
briefly describe what we did in this work.
So we built a method
to see the H&E images
that all the cancer patients have,
read out the 11 TMA spatial clusters
across these 28,000 genes. And
from that, we classify the 1,400 patient
into two spatial types, which is the strongest predictor for the
survival,
and also a predictor for the
treatment response. And it required no sequencing,
no fresh tissue, and without any extra cost.
So in future direction, we want to include some high-resolution spatial
data that include spatial HD and the
Xenium. Also, the
validation we did on the cross-validation, so we want to include the other
multi-institutional cohort for the validation.
So if you are interested, we like to collaborate so that we can push it further.
So please, if you're interested, please reach out.
All of this will not be
done without our supervisor, Dr. Eytan Ruppin, our
incredible team at NCI and Cedars-Sinai, our
collaborator from University of Southampton and Taiwan
Veteran Hospital, who provided us the H&E images and
all the clinical data. Again, if you are interested, please reach out to us.
I have given the email ID. Thank you.
This talk is open for questions.
So just to kick things off, I'll ask a couple of questions
to kick things off. So
one question is, the method is very interesting.
It shows a lot of promise, but it's kind of premised on how
well it can predict the spatial transcriptomics from the
H&E, right? And in the data you showed, where you showed
on the initial dataset where you showed that you're able to do it, it looks like
the correlations are fairly maybe moderate.
I want to say it's in the lower range.
Yes. So this is
one of the biggest
drawbacks, I would say. So the spatial transcriptomic
data is sparse, and also the training data that we are using,
the expressed genes is around 18,000, but the
external validation data that we are using, that is around 10,000.
Mm-hmm.
So it's just the half of this. So that's why the number of genes is
lesser. So that's why the correlation is also not that good.
I have a question about
spatial types.
Yes.
When you describe spatial types, so maybe you mentioned it and I missed it, but I
wasn't sure what about the spatial types are you using
that gets fed into the model to predict outcomes?
So
no, we are not using the spatial type. We are using the spatial cluster.
So from the 11 spatial cluster,
so we represent each of the patient by the 11 spatial cluster
abundance, and we train the model on that
vector of 11 number presentation.
Sorry, like the density of the clusters?
Or-
No. The proportion of the cluster
in each slide.
Oh, got it. Thanks.
Cool.
I can ask this one.
Yeah.
So it was actually really good. One of the questions I had when I read your
abstract was, you're showing the prognostic value.
How do you show the predictive value?
But you have that covered in the slides, so that was interesting.
When you say that you can predict response, what I was curious
about is what is the definition of response in your cohort?
So it's complete response and--
I mean, responder or non-responder. Complete response and yeah.
You're using-
Like clinical?
Clinical, yes.
I see.
Yeah.
Do we have any other questions from the audience?
The last question I'll ask is, so the spatiotypes are
giving you this very strong signal, right?
Yes.
But essentially it is based off those clusters, those-
Those 11 clusters
... those 11 clusters, right?
Yes.
So how would you validate those clusters?
I know you're showing the correlation with the gene expression, but-
So yeah.
So what we did is that
we took the TCGA as the discovery
cohorts. Those 11 spatial cluster
signature we transferred to the other cohort like Hancock and the
Taiwan, and we check how much correlated the clusters
expressions are, and they are very correlated. Yeah.
Okay.
If there are no other questions, we'll thank the speaker once again. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
All right, so we'll move on to the next talk, to be presented by
Dan Thai Hoang. The title of the talk is Pan-Cancer
Prediction of Response to Immune Checkpoint Blockade from
Histopathology.
Good afternoon, everyone. So my name is Thai Hoang,
a research scientist from Cedars-Sinai.
So first of all, thank you so much for giving me the opportunity to
present our work today. So today, I'm going to talk about
pan-cancer prediction of ICB response from pathology
slide.
So I have no financial relationship to disclose.
So I divided my talk into five sections.
After a brief introduction of the research question,
I will be explaining the computational framework,
and I will showing our result for predicting
tumor hotness and also ICB response using the
measured gene expression as well as using the inferred gene
expression from histopathology slide.
And then finally, I will summarize my talk.
So what was the motivation of our study?
So in this study, we try to address two research questions.
First, can we derive a pan-cancer signature of
tumor hotness and use it to predict ICB response?
The second question is that can we infer the tumor hotness and
predict ICB response directly from histopathology
slide without the need of sequencing?
So to address the question, Sumit Mukherjee and
Sumit Bhatia, two amazing fellows in our lab,
they leverage
immune score,
inflammation score, and number of TMB from TCGA
melanoma sample to get a composite score of
tumor hotness, and use that score to get label
for hot and cold sample. And then they
perform a DGE analysis to identify a
signature of tumor hotness, which we call as TAHMAC,
consisting of 60 CG. And now
using that signature,
we identify tumor hotness and predict
ICB response from the
measured gene expression as well as using the inferred gene
expression from histopathology slide.
And now I will show you here the result for predicting
tumor hotness and ICB response using the measured gene
expression. As you can see here, in term of predicting
tumor
hotness, we are able to achieve an AUC of
0.98 across 11 cohorts.
So which is not perfect yet, but nearly.
So
strikingly, as you see here,
our signature was only derived from
TCGA melanoma sample. However, it's generalized very
well to other cancer type as well. So which is amazing.
Now in term of predicting ICB response, which is of course
more challenging, and we mainly to collect a large data
set of 22 transcriptomic cohort, which
is based on our
understanding the
largest cohort so far. So we achieve an AUC of
0.74 across the
22 transcriptomic cohort. And we benchmarking
with other
26 established ICB response signature and
also other established method, and we saw that
our
signature outperform all other existing
established ICB response signature and also method.
So which is exciting. But let's move to another
more exciting part to us.
So
in term of
digital pathology, we recently developed Path2omic,
a deep learning model for predicting gene expression and
methylation across 30 cancer
type. And we saw that Path2omic can reportedly
predict around 6,000 genes for each cancer type,
and it work three times better than our previous
approach, the PIT, Public In nature Cancer, two year ago.
So you can see how the field is moving.
So given that,
we ask can we predict
tumor hotness and ICB response using the inferred gene
expression without the need of measured
sequencing?So to do
that, we first evaluate Path2Omic model performance
for the TAM genes in comparison with all other genes.
As you can see here,
the histogram of the distribution
correlation between the measured gene expression and the inferred
gene expression for each cancer type for the TAM genes in
comparison with all other genes. And you see here, TAM genes are
among the most accurately inferred from
Path2Omic.
So I was so happy when I saw this figure, and I told to
Sumit Mukherjee and Sumit Bhatia that, "My
Path2Omic fall in love with your TAM
genes" because it is a very good combination
between TAM and Path2Omic.
So given a positive signal, we try to
predict tumor hotness directly from slide using the
inferred gene expression from head and neck.
And as you can see here, we obtain a mean AUC of
0.96 across eight TCGA
cancer types, which is nearly as good as that obtained by
using measured gene expression.
Now moving to predict ICP response.
So we collect
nine
new
independent external ICP cohorts, and
we use a pre-trained Path2Omic model
which was trained on TCGA data and
apply as it is without any further training.
And we obtain an AUC of 0.72 across the
nine cohorts and an odds ratio of
five. And as you see here, outperforms the classical
direct approach with train on
cross-validation to predict treatment response directly from
slide without the intermediate step of inferring gene
expression. So which is very encouraging.
So in summary, in this work, we derive a new
ICP response called TAM-HOT, and we show that TAM-HOT
accurately classifies tumor hotness and achieve a mean
AUC of 0.98 across
all the cohorts that we evaluated.
And TAM-HOT outperforms 26 established ICP
response signatures and methods.
And in term of predicting
using inferred gene expression from slide, we show that TAM genes
can be accurately inferred from histopathology slide,
and it work as good as measured gene expression.
So now moving further step, we ask, can we develop a
model based on slide, but that can work better than the measured gene
expression?
Because as we saw here,
our method based on histopathology slide work as good as
measured gene expression, but we want to move a further step.
Try to build
a model that can work better than the measured gene expression.
So some of the work was shown by our
PI talk a few minutes ago in this section.
In case you miss, then I just show you one slide from his
presentation. So here is our moving forward, that we
try to build a model to predict spatial tumor
hotness.
So on the first column is the
actual head and neck slide, and the
middle column here is the actual hotness
that was gathered using the Visium
data set. And here is our inferred hotness.
And we hope that
the spatial tumor hotness can
outperform the burn level that we
obtained previously. And with that, I would like to thank
to our amazing fellow, Sumit Mukherjee and Sumit
Bhatia, who led this project, and my PI, of course, and thank you for
listening. I'm happy to take any questions.
Do we have any questions for the speaker?
All right, maybe I'll get started.
So,
excellent talk. Very fascinating results.
My question is,
why did you start with melanoma, and what about melanoma
biology do you think would
probably allow you to
predict hotness across other cancers?
Thank you very much. That is a very good question.
So first of all, as you know, melanoma is a more
response to ICP, right? And to create
and
to derive the signature, we have to start with a clean
label, hot and cold, and melanoma is one of the more one,
so we start with that first. But in the future, and
we are actively working on that to get
ICP signature based on the pan-cancer model,
not only using melanoma sample, but using
different cancer type as well.
Yeah, but then to my second question,
maybe if you have some thoughts around what about the biology
would be relevant from melanoma that would translate to other cancers that could be
relevant?
Right. So
my thought is that, first of all, I have to declare that I'm
a physicist, so I'm clueless about biology, okay?
So what I thought is something not correct.
But based on my understanding, because here is immune
signature, so there are some-... common
feature from melanoma to other cancer type.
So that's why we will be able
to attract the feature and get the biological
feature from melanoma and apply to other
cancer type. And as we already saw that although our
signature was derived from melanoma, it generalize well
to other cancer type.
Yeah, I'm not sure if I can handle that.
No, that's good.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Yes.
Yeah. It's really interesting data.
I was wondering about metastatic tumors, if
all of this was in primary
H&E slides versus metastatic, and how you would
expect this to play out when you have heterogeneity across
different metastatic sites and cancers, and inferring
the same signature. Yeah.
Very good question. Thank you so much.
First of all
at start project, we
normally prioritize our work on
primary tumor, which is easier and
it is easier to start with. However,
we already found that actually in this work,
in The Kids' NIH cohort,
there are
metastatic sample in it. And we saw that
although the model was derived from primary, it still
generalize very well to metastasis.
And as you know from TCGA, most of the
sample
in melanoma, they are metastatic actually.
Go ahead.
Okay, quick question. Very exciting talk. Thank you.
You showed us the correlation between your score and
various gene signatures, for
hotness of the tumor. But you started
off telling us that you were looking at something that could be used for
predicting response to immune checkpoint inhibitors.
So clinically,
currently it's not a gene expression signature, it's an
immunohistochemical stain that's used.
Did you look to correlate to see
how you compared to that?
Very good question. So
we really want to make that comparison.
Unfortunately, currently we don't have the ICP
measure for the dataset we have. So we would love
to evaluate our model
performance and explore the correlation if you have the data, and
we are very happy to collaborate with you.
Okay. Thank you.
I have another question, and maybe this is a naive question, maybe I missed it, but
I was curious how do you define hotness?
What is the definition of hotness?
Very good question. So
our fellow, Sumit Mukherjee and Sumit Bhatia, they
combine three
information, immune score, inflammation score,
and the number of TMB, and they
define the
tumor hotness based on at least two of them, they are on
the top high, and if two of them, at least two of them,
they are on the bottom, and they define cold to get a
clear distinction between hot and cold.
I see. So the image that you were showing towards the end with
the actual hotness and predicted hotness, what
was actual hotness there? The-
Right.
The actual hotness is based on at
least two
criteria, they are hot
and cold.
She's talking about where you have the comparison to the spatial, the last slide
where you showed from Dr. Rabin.
Oh, the last slide. Sorry. I'm so sorry.
Can I go to the last slide? Do you want me to show that one?
I think he might be able to open up the-
Or is it-- Right.
So,
okay. Is it? Okay.
All good. So to get-
Yeah, I think you should be able to go to the slide.
Right.
This is on-
Yes, this one
... going to the way.
Yeah.
So here,
the slide is from the vision spatial
transcriptomics. So to get the up to hotness here,
we use actual gene expression as a spot level,
and we use the signature that we have,
and then we get that actual hotness.
So this is spatial transcriptomics?
That is correct.
Got it.
That is correct. But you know that is for model training and evaluation,
but then after one we train that we will be able to apply as it is
to infer the spatial hotness to other external
cohort.
Got it. Thank you.
I think there's one more question. Go ahead. Just a quick question.
Just going to add to the question that you were just asking.
So the actual hotness here, is it T cells or is it a more
composite?
Not really T cell. That a very good question.
We found a very correlation between actual hotness and
T cell. But as you
see the whole of this project is to derive a signature to
measure the hotness. So the hotness here was compute
based on our signature, based on the 66 gene.
Okay.
All right. Let's thank our speaker again. Thank you very much.
Okay. The next speaker is Eric
Bergstrom,
and the title of his talk is A Large Scale Multi-Target Deep
Learning Model for Virtual Genomic Profiling in Colorectal Cancer.
I'd just like to thank the chairs for hosting and for the opportunity to
speak today. So here are my financial disclosures.
And so before we jump into the actual results, I first want to introduce one of the
main tests that we actually perform at Natera,
which is called Signatera. And this is a circulating tumor DNA test,
it's a blood-based test where we're trying to detect molecular residual disease so
that we can actually track patients' trajectories over time and monitor for this
recurrence. And the way this works is we can take the tumor
biopsy or the tissue itself and construct a unique fingerprint for that patient's
tumor itself, and then we can track that fingerprint in the blood over time.
And so, of course, anytime we introduce this concept of molecular sequencing for
clinical actionability, we always have this time delay from the point when we take
that initial tissue sample to the point where we can actually make clinical
actionability or insights. And so our team at Natera
came up or wanted to ask the question rather, can we actually intervene at an
earlier stage? And can we use more routinely sampled data like H&E
digital pathology as an orthogonal signal to actually augment
the information we're gaining from the molecular sequencing.
And the goal here is to see, can we provide an earlier
signal for genetic mutations, genomic drivers, and can we also pull
out patients that are at higher risk for molecular recurrence.
Ultimately, the goal here is to better
put these patients under enhanced surveillance or to try to more
optimally align them with different clinical trials.
And so the reason we actually started approaching this question at Natera was due
to our large data synchronization that was possible.
So for this specific study, we're looking at colorectal cancer, where we actually
aggregated 45,000 individual patients that have digital H&E
images, whole exome sequencing data, as well as longitudinal
ctDNA that allows us to track that molecular recurrence over time.
Importantly, we were also able to aggregate 21,000 additional samples as an
external cohort that also has the same paired data.
And so what we took as our initial step is very familiar to anyone here who does
any of these deep learning digital pathology pipelines.
We constructed this end-to-end digital H&E assessment pipeline, which essentially
takes the image as input. We perform very canonical image
preprocessing steps where we remove background, we account for stain normalization,
and we ultimately tile these images into smaller patches that are more
manageable for some of the very popular and existing foundation models.
So we pass these tiles through these frozen foundation models, and in the end,
we're training this downstream aggregation head, which in this case happens to be a
transformer-based architecture, where we're actually encoding the 2D
positional information of the tiles with the goal of trying to capture local and
global context of the images themselves.
And in the end, what we're actually trying to predict again is an early screening
or imputation of genetic drivers, which we're calling virtual genomics,
and also to see whether or not we can actually predict molecular recurrence or at
least get an early signal from these H&E images.
And so again, based on the idea that we have this paired data for each of these
patients, we're able to train against whole exome sequencing data as that
baseline risk or state of the tumor.
And we can also leverage the ctDNA to model the molecular recurrence over
time.
So it's been well established in the literature in digital pathologies, we can
detect genetic alterations from the H&E slides, but given the scalability of our
cohort, we wanted to revisit this and see at what maximum
predictive capacity can we actually obtain.
So we trained a series of different models here to predict mutations across
individual genes. Specifically, we focused in on the MSK Impact cohort
or panel of cancer genes, and we found that for over 80% of these
genes, we achieved an AUC above 0.7, and we were able
to generalize many of these models in our external cohort.
So this kind of validated the common notion in the
field that we can use H&E as an early signal, but we wanted to see if we could push
that predictive capacity a little bit further.
And so given the scale, we actually modeled this as a multitask
prediction. So instead of training individual models to predict these mutations
individually, we wanted to train a single model to predict all
463 genes simultaneously for a single patient.
And the intuition for doing this is we thought we could capture complementary
information across the genomic landscape for a single patient that might enhance
our ability to screen for individual genes.
And so as we hypothesized, we did see these results where we improved the
performance for 95% of these genes in the cohort, and
over almost 40% of these were able to increase their AUC by
5%.
So again, this started to show us that we can leverage still H&E a little bit
further as you start to scale this cohort's in size.
But the real question is how can we actually move this towards clinical
actionability? So you can screen across these genes in general.
They might tell you something about the tumor biology, but the reality is we still
need to follow some of the NCCN guidelines that are still in place.
So we revisited some of these colorectal specific guidelines here looking at
microsatellite instability, BRAF V600E mutations, POLE,
POLD1 hypermutation, and KRAS alterations.
And so training individual models to refine our predictive capacity in each
of these indications showed we reached state-of-the-art accuracy across all of
these different biomarkers. For specifically on those microsatellite
instability, achieving an AUC of 0.98.
More importantly, though, we demonstrate that we can also generalize these models
to our external cohorts, suggesting we are capturing robust
signals here from the morphology.
We decided to take a little bit of a deeper dive specifically into the BRAF V600E
model to
get under the transparency of these models to try to understand what's going on.
And while we have high concordance with the whole exome sequencing, these models
still aren't perfect in terms of replicating what we see in the sequencing.
So we wanted to better understand in those patients where we're confident that we
should see a BRAF V600E mutation, but we don't see it in the sequencing, what's
actually going on there. So we took a look at these samples, and for over
50% of them, we're actually finding alterations in alternative genes in the same
MAPK pathway that BRAF belongs to.So what this starts to suggest
is that we're capable of capturing these convergent morphological phenotypes at
the pathway level rather than at the individual gene level.
And that's still interesting because we're demonstrating we can still show high
concordance with targeted alterations, but that we can also capture adjacent
biology.
But again, the question comes up whether that's meaningful clinically.
So biologically, that's quite interesting, but does that actually affect individual
patient trajectory?
So again, if you remember, we have the paired ctDNA for each of these patients.
So what we can actually do is monitor the molecular recurrence over time, so
essentially how well are they doing clinically.
And we can see
typically when you have a BRAF V600E mutation, and that's agreeing
morphologically and with the whole exome sequencing, these patients tend to do
worse, shown in green, especially compared to wild type patients.
But if we hone in specifically on the patients where the H&E-based model thinks
there should be a mutation but we don't observe one, essentially false positives,
we actually see that same worse overall performance
or trajectory for these patients.
And so that starts to reiterate that we are capturing these pathway-level
specific information and that it actually does have clinical impact for these
patients.
And so the natural evolution for our thought process here was this is great, but
can we actually just detect the molecular recurrence directly from the H&E slides?
So we trained a
Cox proportional hazard risk model here to output a continuous risk score for each
of these patients based off their ctDNA molecular recurrence
trajectories. And we did show that we can indeed separate these patients into these
high and low-risk subcategories.
But more importantly, we want to investigate whether or not these types of models
can augment or help out what we're already doing with our MRD
testing.
So in the colorectal cancer setting, it's been shown in a prognostics
way that if you actually look at an MRD test post-surgery, so within 12 weeks
post-surgery, dependent on if that test is positive or negative, gives
you prognostic indication for how the patient's going to do longer term.
And so we found that if we actually look in the MRD negative group, where these
patients tend to do better overall than the positive groups, we can actually
further stratify that if we incorporate H&E-based risk predictions.
And again, like we showed before, we're also able to generalize these in our
external cohort, suggesting we are capturing robust morphological features within
these models.
And so as a final experiment that we wanted to perform, given the scalability of
our cohort here, we wanted to investigate whether or not we've actually achieved
our maximum predictive capacity here or whether scaling these cohorts
further would actually be of benefit.
So if you take a biomarker like microsatellite instability, that's basically the
poster child for deep learning AI, we achieved an AUC of 0.9 with
our full cohort, but if you randomly sample this data set smaller and smaller, we
can basically analyze the performance increase over time as we
increase that cohort. And what we see is that we actually plateau quite early.
We only need about 1,000 or 2,000 positive mutated examples to
plateau that performance. It's a very highly penetrant
phenotype. We know it associates quite closely with inflammation.
But if you look at another biomarker like KRAS, which has a more heterogeneous
underlying tumor biology, we're noticing that we still have yet to even hit that
inflection point of accuracy. And so we believe that
revisiting these models in the future as we continue to scale our cohorts will
actually provide benefit.
And then the second finding that came out of this analysis was dependent
on the size of the data set you're starting with, that initial choice of your
foundation model is crucial. But as you start to scale that cohort
larger and larger, the choice of that initial foundation model becomes less and
less relevant as we converge to that same maximum predictive capacity.
And so with that, I just want to summarize that I hope I've shown that we are now
operating at a large scale that allows us to actually screen for a wide range of
different genomic alterations directly from these H&E images in the hope to
complement and accelerate actionability for individual
patients. We're shown also from a biological perspective that we're
capturing pathway-level information that also translate to clinical
actionability for these individual patients.
And lastly, we're hoping again to leverage these H&E images as a way to pre-screen
and prioritize how we go about diagnosing and treating these
patients and ultimately better matching them for specific clinical trials.
And very specifically to colorectal cancer, we're hoping that we can actually
introduce this type of methodology to the MRD testing as an orthogonal signal to
actually improve how that adjuvant decision-making is actually taking place
for the individual patients. And so with that, I'd just like to thank
the members of our team at Natera and for all the scientists and leaders that
helped make this possible, and happy to take any questions.
This talk is open for questions. Go ahead.
Thank you for that exciting talk. Can you share with us a
little bit any confounders you found along the
way that threw the models off, and tell us a bit about that journey?
Yeah, no, it's a great question.
Yeah, there's multiple confounders.
So you have obvious confounders with using different
scanners. That's one of the bigger components here.
Coming from different sites even is a bigger component.
So that's where we
at scale, what we're seeing is that when you scale large enough, with
real-world data, you start to capture a lot of those confounders inherently in the
data set, and that once you train these models end to end,
you actually remove a lot of those confounders.
That being said, though, we do see differential performance if you're looking at
biopsy versus resection slides. So biopsy, you obviously tend to have less
quality tissue to work with.
That's just an inherent limitation to the data.
So we're still investigating how to maximize that. Thanks. Thank you.
Very nice talk. I have two questions.
The first, are you generating one model per gene or is it one
model per variant, like KRAS has multiple
variations?Yeah, great question.
So it was an evolution through the presentation and through our
mindset when we were building these.
So we built them originally as individual models to assess where we're at as a
baseline, and then have since moved towards multitask learning.
So now we're predicting them all simultaneously.
For the NCCN guided markers, we see there's been some other studies from Campanella
and so forth, looking at EGFR, like in the SILENT trial, where they show it
actually improves the model to actually focus on a single target in that setting
when you know there's a clear actionability.
So for the NCCN markers, we have individual models.
Awesome. Thank you. And then what's your sensitivity?
Is there a minimum variant allele frequency that you set as
positive, or can you find things that are even low frequency?
Yeah, that's a great question. We still need to dig deeper into that.
We haven't done an extensive analysis on that yet. Yeah. Great question.
Thank you.
Hi. Thank you. Very interesting talk, very clinically relevant.
So thank you so much. I was wondering about the mutations, because in
one of the first slide, the most prevalent mutations were actually the lowest
AUCs. And in the further slides, you
showed that as you increase the number of slides
that you have, the higher the AUCs go.
Yeah. That's a great question. One of the ones that stands out in that figure
you're talking about is actually APC, which is one of the most prevalent
drivers in colorectal cancer. So I think 70% to 80% of all tumors will
have that. So as a result, it's not distinguishable, I would say.
There's less distinguishing morphological characteristics.
It's an early event in the evolution, so we see less of it in the final tumor
phenotype. Great question.
Thank you.
It's a really interesting talk. JP Shen from MD Anderson.
You mentioned that the performance on biopsy versus surgical resection is sometimes
different. Have you looked at downsampling?
Like how many images are-- because our pathologists don't-- It's not uniform
how many slides are actually getting scanned in a digital imaging.
I was wondering if you could comment on how many slides or how many digital
images do you need per
patient before you start to see loss of the signal.
I see. So you're asking if you could take multiple imaging
per patient. We haven't looked at that directly. It's a great question.
We do have access to multiple slides per patient, and it's something we can
investigate, but we haven't done that exactly.
But I think that's something people are investigating specifically in the biopsy
setting like you mentioned.
Great. Thank you.
Thanks.
Hey, super cool work. I have two questions.
I think one was partially answered now.
I was just wondering if there are any patterns that you see for given biomarkers in
your scaling laws.
And I guess the second question is for the independent models.
I'm not sure how you did the aggregation, but if it
was using attention, did you actually see differences
between the attention maps?
Oh yeah, great question. Yeah. So for interpretability, this is an
ongoing field.
Yeah.
Obviously, across digital pathology as a whole, but also for our specific
experiments. For instance, if we take something like the risk model, we are seeing
unique morphological phenotypes, largely associated with things like tumor stromal
ratio, which we know is an indicator of risk.
And then we've also validated some of the more canonical ones like MSI.
We see the inflammation and so forth.
For models that have fairly high accuracy, where we don't necessarily see that
huge gain as we move towards the multitask setting, the attention maps don't change
much. When you're with something that has very low performance and we scale
up and we see that improvement, they do change quite a lot.
All right, sweet. Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you.
If there are no more questions, let's thank the speaker again. Thank you.
All right, so our next talk is titled, "AI-Driven
Spatial Cell Classification and Tumor Infiltration Lymphocyte Patch
Analysis Reveal Spatial Immunarchitecture in
Arsenic-Associated Bladder Cancer." The speaker,
Sonalka Singhal, couldn't join us today, so this will be presented by
Sandip Singhal.
Are they here?
Sandip?
All right. Maybe not. We'll move on to the next talk then.
I guess so. The talk was online, though.
All right. I guess we'll just move on.
We can come back to them.
Yeah.
If they show up.
All
right.
Let's see. Hopefully, we have our next speaker here.
We'll move on to the next talk,
by Ajay Rajaraman Subramanian. All right,
good. You're here. Title of the talk is, "Peritumoral Collagen
Microarchitecture is Differentially Prognostic of Biochemical
Recurrence Across Populations in Prostate Cancer."
Hello, all. My name is Ajay Rajaraman Subramanian, and
I'm a second-year PhD student in Georgia Institute of Technology,
and I'm also a part of Emory University as well.
So the topic that I'll be presenting on is
peritumoral collagen microarchitecture is differently prognostic of
biochemical recurrence across populations in prostate cancer.
So basically,
the extracellular matrix is the underlying structure that
surrounds and supports the cells in the tissue.
So we have seen that there has been multiple studies that have shown that the
extracellular matrix remodeling is associated with prostate
cancer.So now, the major component of the
extracellular matrix is the collagen fibers.
So
the thing is, the peritumoral collagen architecture has
both the stromal organization and tumor aggressiveness.
And there have been studies that have shown that the collagen
fibers' orientation and the
structure can be associated with tumor aggressiveness.
Also, African American men have 1.5 to
2X higher prostate mortality when compared to European American.
And evidences have shown that there is a difference
in the tumor biology and their aggressiveness.
So now,
can we use a one size fit all model
for these patients and still see the differences
in their
tumor microenvironment? So over here, the key question is, do
population-specific collagen signatures identified in African
American or European American patients carry prognostic
value within and across populations?
So here is our study design. So we have African American and
European American patients, and there is 101 African American
and 101 European American
radical prostatectomy whole slide images.
And our clinical endpoint is biochemical recurrence, and we are doing
survival analysis, which I'll be explaining shortly how we are going to be doing
that.
So the way we are doing this is we take the H&E slide images,
and we extract the tumor regions from these
H&E
regions. And using these tumor regions, we extract the
peritumoral regions, and we extract the patches from the peritumoral
region, and we have a deep learning-based algorithm that extracts
collagen. And using this collagen that we have extracted
using the deep learning-based architecture, we are extracting features, and we are
doing survival analysis.
Over here, we are seeing three different categories of features.
So the first one is structural features, the second one is spatial features,
and the last one being textural features.
So as I mentioned earlier, we are doing survival analysis.
So here is the method that we are using for doing the survival analysis.
So as I mentioned earlier, there are 101 European American and 101
African American patients. So right now, we are splitting the data
set as 80% for training and 20% for testing.
In those 80% training set, we have made sure that there is
exact number of African American and Caucasian American patients.
And in the test set as well, we have made sure that there is equal number of
African American and Caucasian American patients.
So over here, what we do is we take the African
American training set only, which is N equal to 80,
and we do univariate analysis where we look at the most important
collagen features in the African
American training cases. And then we use these features
that we get from the African American training cases.
We do three types of analysis. The first being, we look at the
entire test set,
the next one being, we look at the African American test set only, and
the last one being, we look at the European American test set,
and we do survival analysis.
As you can see over here, the features extracted from the African
American training set, the most prognostic
features that we extracted from the African American training set using univariate
analysis, was able to
stratify risk in the entire test set, where we can see that the P
value is 0.02, which is significant, and our
hazard ratio is 4.09. As you can see, even in the test set
for the African American only, it is able to stratify risk.
But for the European American, unfortunately, the African American
features are not working well.
Over here, we did something similar.
So we looked at the European
American features only, and we tried to
stratify risk on the entire cohort, and unfortunately, the P
value was not significant, and the hazard ratio was
1.89.
Even on the African American and the European American
test set, these features were not able to
stratify risk.
So as you can see, these were the nine prognostic features in the African
American
train set, and these were the prognostic features for the
European American train set. And we can see that there is only
one shared feature, which is the Haralick entropy variability, which
was common between these two feature sets.
So we know that there is a different collagen signature for
European American and African American.
And we can see that when we look at the extracted
features, as I showed earlier, the feature categories that we had
extracted, we can see around
15 features that were statistically significant
between the European American and African American.
Over here, I'm just trying to show two features that were
statistically significant. One is the texture entropy, and the other
one is gray-level co-occurrence matrix entropy.
You can see that for the African American patient, there is
a higher entropy, whereas for the
European American patient, there is lesser entropy.
So over here, we are trying to compare the same Gleason grade
to look at the entropy.
And another thing is, these are the statistically significant features
for the African American and the Caucasian American patients.
You can see that there are very less number of features that are more
in the African American, and most of the features are actually more in the European
American.And these are all texture-related features, and none of the
morphology or spatial-related features were actually picked up.
So coming to the conclusion. So we were able to see that the
African-American and the European-American men have
different peritumoral collagen microarchitectures.
And we could see that only one of nine African-American specific
features overlapped with the European-American specific features.
And we were able to also see that the African-American features were
able to drive whole cohort prognostication, whereas the
European-American
features did not do that.
And the cross-population validation, the African-American features
did work on the African-American test set, whereas the
European-American features did not work even on the
European-American patients.
So now, here comes the key takeaway from this
presentation. As I've demonstrated, we cannot use one size fit
all kind of model for these types of data set.
So we'll have to
do something where we look at the different populations
and try to come up with
the features for different populations.
I would like to thank my PI, Dr. Anant Madabhushi, the post-doc of our
lab, Dr.
Naoto Tokiyama, and the pathologist of our lab, Dr.
Tilak Patak, and our collaborator, Dr.
Preeti Lal from University of Pennsylvania, for helping me
finish this project. And I would also like to thank my
colleagues and my friends who are part of this lab.
Thank you, and we are open to collaborating. Thank you so much.
This talk is open for questions.
Hi. Great presentation. I have a technical question
about how do you do the peritumor
identification in the first place.
Is that
manual pathology annotation or you use some algorithm?
Yeah. So the thing is, we have manual annotations for tumor
identification, and then we dilate the mask and subtract
the tumor region to get the peritumoral band. So this is how it's done.
And the reason why we have chosen a particular micron
is that we were looking at different micron sizes, and we
saw that around 250 microns was the right
bandwidth for the peritumoral region assessment.
Thank you.
Yeah.
That's interesting. I was wondering about the Gleason scores.
Did you actually also stratify not just by race,
but by Gleason
for your-
Yeah.
... collagen readouts and how that correlated
with Gleason scores-
That's an interesting-
... across the two groups? Yeah.
Yeah, that's an interesting question.
So the thing is, for now, we are just looking at different
races, and we are going to look at how the Gleason
scores, and even we have other endpoints as well, like metastasis is
affecting the--
Looking at that as an endpoint, not Gleason score, but we can look at Gleason
score for classification tasks. So that analysis is yet to
be done, so hopefully we can do it in the future.
Great talk. Very exciting results.
My question is about the biology, right?
So you're suggesting that there are different unique signatures
depending on the
ethnicity of
your population.
What do you think is driving the differences?
Okay. So the first thing, the way the
assessments and the screening and the initial tests are done,
I think that is one of the main key factors.
And also there has been studies that have
demonstrated that there is a significant
difference between the tumor microenvironment of African-American
and European American patients. So again, as I
mentioned, if we use a single model
for the entire cohort,
the signal gets diluted, right? So-
No. So that part I understand. I think the rationale is clear, and it
makes sense.
Right. Yeah.
I guess the question is, and especially because you mentioned tumor
microenvironment, you're not necessarily looking at tumor microenvironment, you're
looking at the peritumoral aspect, right?
So what about the peritumoral aspect is different?
Because you were showing that on one population in African-Americans,
there was-- No, I think in European population, it was more textural
based features, and then in the African-American, it was sort of
more diversity of features. So I'm just curious about maybe your thoughts and
just sort of connecting your results to the underlying
biology.
Exactly. So
the thing is,
as I've mentioned, the features that were significant in the
African-American and the European-American, I showed nine features and
six features, right? So we can see, as you mentioned, there is a diversity
in the features that we get from getting texture and
morphology features in the African-American cohort.
And in the European-American cohort, it's more of texture-related features.
So the assumption is that this is something that is
yet to be explored, but I'm just trying to give a crack at this question.
So the thing is, the collagen architecture that we are looking at in the
peritumoral region,
if
you look at the Gleason grade distribution, it's almost equal
for both the cohorts. So
the main takeaway is that there is a significant difference
in the collagen architecture between European American
andAfrican Americans. So the biology is
something that is not something that I'm aware of, but I
could explain
in detail probably offline.
Yeah. I guess a question along a similar line.
I
don't know anything about prostate cancer.
Is there a difference in the disease in the two populations?
The prostate gland has an inherent anatomy.
Does the tumor occur in the same part of the gland?
Are the differences in collagen simply reflecting anatomical
differences within the prostate gland?
Yeah, that's a very interesting question.
So that is something that we are still exploring and maybe
our work can demonstrate that.
And my second question is how many slides did you look at per
patient?
So we have 101
African American-
Was it just one representative slide per patient, or did you-- Because often
the-
Yeah
... tumors are multifocal, I understand.
Yeah, we just have one-
Just one, okay
... whole slide means per patient. Yes.
Thank you.
Yep.
Thank you very much for this interesting talk, especially from a technical
perspective. I was wondering why you are so sure that this
is collagen you're seeing. You didn't show any data that you
stained for collagen or did any collagen-specific stain.
These are just H&E stains. So I wonder whether just saying
ECM fibers would be more accurate than-- Because your talk was
very collagen-focused without ever showing any
real collagen, right?
Exactly. So the thing is, that's actually a really nice question.
So we do have a few analyses that we have done and
which we will be publishing soon regarding that.
So, over here, we are actually looking at the collagen, and this is
being validated by the pathologists, and they have mentioned that
the collagen segmentation is accurate, roughly
around 75% to 80%, is the claim that is being made.
And we are doing a more quantitative
analysis to get that through. So-
But still, how do the pathologists verify that
it's collagen?
Because I'm a clinician myself, and I know that
people talk about collagen all the time, but no one actually really-- I think you
would need something like an antibody stain or something, or there are
specific stains like Picrosirius red stains, which are not
100%, but they get close to it. H&E, I think would be difficult to
make that claim that this is really collagen, what you're seeing.
Exactly. So the thing is we have unpaired
mason trichrome stain data.
Okay.
So that way we are validating how the performance is-
Yeah
... for segmenting the collagen.
That would have been more convincing for me.
Exactly, yeah.
Thank you.
All right. Let's thank the speaker once again for an excellent talk.
All right.
So we move on to the last talk for this session unless the other speaker
shows up. Oh, wait, somebody's here. I guess this is for the next talk. All right.
So
the next talk for the session is PathIO, a deep learning pathomics
framework for personalized immunotherapy selection and outcome prediction
in metastatic non-small cell lung cancer, and our speaker is Rukmini
Bandopadhyay.
Good afternoon. Sorry. Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Rukmini Bandopadhyay from MD Anderson Cancer Center.
I'm a postdoctoral fellow, and I'd like to talk about our
work, PathIO, a deep learning-based framework for outcome
prediction in metastatic non-small cell lung cancer.
So I do not have any financial relationships to disclose.
So here I'd like to start... Sorry.
Yeah. I'd like to start with a whole slide image
that every patient has, and
immunotherapy treatment on these whole slide images have heterogeneous
response. And also existing biomarkers like PD-L1 and
others, they are often inconsistent, and some of them are very
expensive. So AI shows a promising solution
for this as it is scalable and cost-effective, and also it
is easily deployable worldwide. But in case of
immunotherapy, we have seen that it lacks in multi-center
validation and often the biological interpretability.
So here we are leveraging deep learning framework to offer new avenue
for reliable patient selection.
So this is our overall study design and integrated workflow.
We started with a multi-center cohorts.
We collected data from our MD Anderson and other than
that, Mayo Clinic, Gustave Roussy, and E1400i
trial data. And after curating this data, we took a
stepwise approach. First, we used this whole slide image to
train a deep learning model to predict the patient outcome.
And after that, we benchmark our model to existing foundation
models to see where our framework stands compared to
that. And also we try to find the underlying tumor
biology behind the prediction. And finally, we do a multimodal
integration to see whether we get a better prediction.
So to start with, our in-house pathologist helped
us annotate these different eight regions from the whole slide
images from MD Anderson data,
tumor, bronchi, stroma, necrosis, and so on.
And then
we train a deep learning model
using these annotated regions. And after we get the
prediction for each of the patches, we stitched it back to this
map, which we call a tissue habitat
map.After
this, we validated our tissue classification framework
on different cohort
on MD Anderson data, and other than that, with TCGA and
CPTAC data. So, and we see that we have a robust
performance
for our tissue habitat classification
framework. So once we get this
tissue habitat map, this is the computational pipeline that we developed
for the risk modeling. So we take the tissue habitat
maps, and then we divide it in small ROIs based on the tissue
presence
on the
ROIs, and then we
take it in a multi-scale and then stack these ROIs
in these different scales. And after these stacked
ROIs, we trained multiple models to get ROI level
risk score, and from there, we got a feature vector encoding
representation for each patient, and then
we train a random survival forest with these patient level risk vectors.
And once we get the risk score from the random survival forest, we
validated on internal MD Anderson cohort and as well as
three external cohorts to stratify the patient outcome.
So here is the Kaplan-Meier plot for different
cohorts for OS and PFS, overall survival and progression-free
survival. And we see a robust performance for
MD Anderson data, and the trial data is 1,400 die.
So beyond this, we also do multivariate adjustment to
see whether PathIO provides any complementary information
compared to the existing clinical factors.
And we see that it is independent
predictor of survival, and also it adds information beyond these
existing clinical factors. And when we do the subgroup analysis,
there also we see that it provides consistent performance across
clinically relevant subgroup.
So then as the foundation models are emerging, so we
benchmark our proposed model with different foundation models, and we
see that for immunotherapy-treated
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer data, our model mostly
outperform or provide comparable performance with these
existing foundation models. And not only that, we
take these features from the
foundation models, and then when we cluster these, we see that
we can say that
as this feature representation do not have any
labels, it is often biologically
not interpretable. In case compared to that, the tissue habitat
map, as we know, like which region belongs to which
category, it is more biologically interpretable.
So beyond this, we've tried to find the underlying tumor biology,
and for this we have these two data, multiplex
immunofluorescence and nanoString data from the trial cohort, and we
correlate the risk score with these two modality of data.
And we see that for the multiplex immunofluorescence
data, the
low-risk patient has more immune cells as compared to the high-risk
patient, which is shown here, like it has more immune cells
present as compared to the high-risk patient.
And compared to that, high-risk patient has more tumor cells compared
to the low-risk patient. And this
is also validated with the nanoString data where we see the same
trend.
So finally,
our model is mostly purely prognostic, but we try
to find its potential clinical utility in
first-line PDL1-high patients. So we see that in case of
progression-free survival where our model predicted as
low-risk patient, it shows that the monotherapy can be helpful,
but in case of high-risk patient, the chemotherapy can be helpful.
So it has potentially guide the immunotherapy selection between
monotherapy versus the combined therapy.
And finally, we did the multi-modal integration.
We have paired data for MD Anderson cohort,
whole slide images, as well as the CT data from the
same cohort. And we took the risk score from our previously
published work, and we then combine all these risk scores from the
CT images and the PathIO risk
score, and then combine it with the different clinicopathological
factors and train a random survival forest to get a composite
model risk score. And when we see the performance of the
composite model with combining all this information,
it boosts the performance as compared to
the other modality alone.
So with this, the take home message could be like, as I've already
mentioned, that routine pathology can be transformed into powerful interpretable
biomarkers, and PathIO add independent value beyond the
current clinical factors. And our
future work would be to refine the predictive utility as it
is purely prognostic at this point of time.
And we are trying to get more data to make a multi-scale
digital twin modeling. And also finally, we will think about a prospective
validation in clinical settings.
I would like to acknowledge all my team members and collaborators, and
also my supervisor.
Thank you for your attention.
This talk is open for questions.
All right. So maybe I'll get us started.
So the comparison that you were showing of your model with
foundation models, could you maybe talk about-
Were you also fine-tuning the foundation models the same way you're fine-tuning
your own model?
No, I'm not fine-tuning the foundation model.
I'm just extracting the features using the foundation model and then use an
attention-based multiple instance learning model to
predict the
risk score from that.
So do you think that if you were to fine-tune, because you are getting patches from
the pathologist, right?
Yeah.
So you are using that for your model as well.
I just wonder if you use the patches that you are getting that are
annotated, and if you fine-tune the foundation model, do you think that
would improve the results of the foundation model?
Yeah, it might be possible. Because that tissue
segmentation part that you are talking about, there we have
not used any foundation model. So what we did, we
take the
annotated patches, we train a ResNet model, and then get the
prediction from the ResNet model.
In that part, we haven't incorporated-
No, I understand that. I was just wondering for more an apples to apples
comparison, it would make sense for the foundation model to be fine-tuned as well,
because you could do that, and in that case, it would be more specific to your
application.
Yeah. Right. But I haven't explored that yet.
But yeah, that's a very good suggestion.
Okay. The other question I had was when you're showing the
comparison with your PathIO independently and
then with PathIO plus,
I think it was with-
CT. Yeah. Path-
With CT. Was it with CT?
Yeah.
I think there's another-
DeepCT, PathIO, and PathIO with the clinical factor.
Yeah, and then there was a composite score-
Composite score
... where the results go up-
Yeah
... substantially.
Yeah.
What about looking at them independently?
Have you looked at just the CT-based model and then just the demographic model,
just the clinical model? Where do they lie by themselves?
Yeah. We have tested that, but I haven't
included those results here yet. But yes, for the
DeepCT model, it is already published and the
C index is almost similar to what
we obtained in PathIO. So 0.63,
around something like that for the OS and 0.6
for PFS. So like that. And for the clinical factors,
I do not recollect at this point of time.
Yeah, no, I'm just wondering because it would be interesting to see the additive
benefit. So where you are is at, let's say, 0.65
with path alone, 0.65 with CT alone, and then
your results go up to 0.75 or 0.8, I don't remember.
But just to understand
where the addition or additive value of the features or
complementarity of features is contributing to the model would be interesting.
Okay. Yeah, sure.
Any more questions? Maybe I'll ask one more question.
For the initial training set that you have where you had a
pathologist do the
patch segmentation,
how many samples do you need? Because I didn't see that information.
When is it enough? Where you're like, "Well, I have just enough patches." Because
it's a lot of work for them to go in and segment these patches out.
Mm-hmm.
How do you know that you have enough patches to create the tumor habitat where
you have confidence in your tumor habitat?
Yeah. We
started with 139 annotated whole slide images.
So the pathologist helped us annotate 139 whole
slide images, and we
started with that, and we have all the results with that.
But yeah, that information I have. Yeah.
Do we have any other questions?
Okay.
If there are no other questions, let's thank the speaker once again.
All right. Since we actually have a little bit of extra time here today,
we thought that for the concluding part, what we could do is we could maybe have
all of the speakers join us here on the stage, and we can do kind of an impromptu
panel discussion and put you guys on the spot with some questions that
we thought of based off the presentations.
So I think the six speakers over here, if you could just come here and sit right
here, and we'll make space for
you.
And then we'll also open it up to the audience.
If you guys have any questions about any of the presentations
today, but just maybe any open-ended questions about digital
pathology and AI, now is the time to ask our
speakers.
We just need one more chair.
Yeah.
I have maybe a naive question because I'm new to this space.
But it looks like a lot of your models are based off of spatial
transcriptome and not spatial proteomics. Is there a reason for that?
Is that a cost thing or just some more widely used
technology for spatial profiling?
Do we have any of the speakers who want to take that?
Maybe the ones who spoke about spatial transcriptomics.
Can you just repeat it? I just-
Yeah. The question is that why look at spatial transcriptomics and not
proteomics. Is that right?
Yeah. So we started with the spatial transcriptomics
first. So
then our
future direction is also including the proteomics data so that we can
understand what is the interaction at the spot level between the
cells. So this is the future direction we are considering
now. Yeah.
Go ahead, please.
Hi, I'm Suzanne Coberly. I'm a human pathologist, and I do a
lot of research, and I'm learning more about the AI
predictions. But I do have an interesting question, which was brought up at
an earlier session.
Can every change be detected by looking at morphology, or
can only some genes and/or proteins
be detected? In other words, if somebody said, "Go out and
predict all of these
various genetic and/or protein changes," are there some that can't be
detected when you just look at the H&E?
Hi. Good question. So,
what we see in our work, so I work in
predicting the spatial transcriptomics from H&E images.
So what we found is that if the gene expression is very low,
we are not able to predict that gene expression because the prediction power
also depends on the variance of the
gene expression across the spot.
Mm-hmm.
So this is one of the limitations that we
found. So we could say that
one modality is not enough to detect
everything. So that's why the people are working towards the
multi-modal methods.
Right.
They're including different modality, including other H&E images,
spatial transcriptomic, proteomics.
Okay.
Anybody else?
Yeah, I can add to that. I think also there's a more fundamental biological
question that's being asked there underlying that.
Yes, exactly.
And yeah. So I think short answer, no, we can't detect
everything.
Right.
And the reality is because you need to have some type of
morphological change that happens.
But not just that, it also needs to potentially be unique to that individual
biomarker. Not necessarily completely unique, but if you have overlapping
biomarkers-
Right
... that are distinguishable, but they relate to that same phenotype, you'll just
detect the phenotype. So for instance, I've seen with a lot of the spatial
transcriptomic models or even the genomic models like I was showing, if you look at
individual performance of these genes, you'll actually see they correlate with one
another-
Right
... like the pathway analysis and so forth.
So there is a limitation and-
Yeah, I've been working with some of the virtual IHC multiplex
people doing protein, and I do know that there's some targets that are harder for
them to predict than others. And is there any way to tell which
targets would be harder, or would you not know, or would that depend
on, say, which cancer you were looking at?
Can I elaborate a little bit?
I'm sorry if that's a stupid question, but we're trying to figure out which
models to pick and where to use this in our research.
Right. That is a very good question, actually.
So
as you know, I have been working intensively on building a model to
predict gene expression. Like in path2omic, we saw that our
model performance on ACRO30
decision cancer type, so which is one of them.
And
I mentioned that we are able to predict around 6,000 genes out
of around 20,000 genes. But importantly, when we
perform the enrichment analysis, and we found that all of
the 6,000 genes there, they are
highly enriched with
cancer hallmark. So they are the most important.
So some genes
not important and randomly, then we cannot predict.
Okay.
So that is the good news. And we saw in our path2omic papers are
using the inferred gene expression, we were able to predict
survival as good as the measured gene expression.
I guess that makes sense.
So that is all we need. We don't need to predict some random gene.
We just need to predict the important gene.
Well, no, I know, but you may not know which is important when you're starting off.
Yeah.
That's the only issue, but I get your point.
Right.
Yeah. Anyway, thank you. Unless somebody else-- That's actually something I just
needed to know for my own-
Yeah, that's a great question. I think as a follow-up to that, one thing that I
wonder, which is a study I haven't seen, but maybe one of you has, and you
guys can talk about it, is there is also the genes that are
dominant at this primary tumors may not be dominant
for recurrence. And so I just wonder if you looked
at spatial organization, spatial arrangement, or even
morphology on pathology, how is that different?
I don't know if that study has been done, but I'm just curious because the gene-
Well, and obviously, that could mean that in different cancers, different genes
would be-- You would be able to take a look at them and predict them because
different genes would be important to that particular cancer type.
Right.
Anyway. I don't want to take over-
And even there are certain genes that change, that evolve over time.
So that's another aspect.
The more delayed genes that change over time.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Any questions you want to ask?
So I'm going to switch tracks a little bit.
So we heard a lot of really cool research on developing these
methods and then showing application for prognosis, prediction, and so on.
So this one, I'm actually going to have each of you answer in turn so that everyone
on the stage gets something to say.
But what I'd like to hear is,
what do you guys think needs to be done, or what's the bar of evidence we
need to get to for these to actually move forward to the next
stage of clinical
usage? Do you think your models are at this stage?
In some cases, I understand they're early stage, so you can maybe tell what you
want to do next with them. But what needs to be done to
actually move these for using in the clinic?
Are there actual errors that need to be still fixed or
are just going to be part of the process that we just have to be aware of because
nothing is ever perfect? So I'll have you guys go in order.
Maybe Eric, you want to start, and we come down the line?
Yeah, I think this is a great question, especially with
digital pathology specifically, even two years ago when AACR was here in San Diego
to now, it's exploded, which is great.
There's a lot of promise here, but at the end of the day, we're still not seeing
that much of it being adopted into the clinic.
And so, yeah, that question is very relevant and timely.
I think Caither actually has a good take on this.
So they've established in the European Union a series of different biomarker
classifications associated with digital pathology into class one, I think it's
class A, B, and C. And so I think there's actually multiple answers depending
on what type of biomarker you're trying to get into the clinic and what level of
evidence you need. So for instance, if it's something that already exists, like
you're replacing microsatellite instability from IHC scoring, we have
a precedent of what needs to be set, and so you need to show high concordance with
that to get it into the clinic. So that comes with reproducibility,
generalizability. But if it's a novel biomarker, you need multiple levels of
evidence for that to actually make it to clinic, and that becomes very difficult,
and I think that's open-ended. We still need to see
how that evolves over time.
That's actually a really interesting question because,
in the recent past,
we develop a lot of new algorithms and stuff like
that, and only 2 or 3% actually gets to the
clinical deployment, whereas the other 97% is
just considered as a novel thing, but it's not being adopted at all.
So,
the
next steps could be for this particular project that I'm working on could
be probably having more cohorts to
actually validate this. That's number one.
And also another thing is we know that Gleason grade is definitely the gold
standard right now for
looking at the prognosis. Maybe what we can
actually do is show that combining
the collagen biomarker plus Gleason grade gives a better
C-index than just using Gleason grade.
So that can be one of the approaches to actually show that it is
working really well. And also another thing is we show that it is
independently significant. So we have a lot of clinical parameters.
So collagen as a biomarker, if it is clinically
independent, then we can say with full confidence that
we can use collagen for clinical deployment.
So
yeah.
Yeah, I will talk more on the general level.
I think
from past few years, a
few startup company already commercialized some of the
pathology tools for simple diagnosis like
tumor segmentation, which
we have the ground truth from the pathologist.
But in terms of our study, which is to develop
algorithms for new biomarkers or for
biomarkers that identified in other
modalities. So I think
this will be hard, and one thing is because the
imaging instrument and also the staining
variation has a lot of variations
across different constitutions.
So
getting extra cohort is, I think, the first
priority for my work.
And also we need to validate--
When we are trying to push it to real clinical use, I
think data transfer between different institute will also
be hard. So maybe
federated learning might be one options I'm thinking
about.
Yeah.
Yeah. I'd like to add three points.
So first is multicenter validation.
If we can include more trial cohorts on our
study, I think that would definitely improve the
generalizability and robustness of the model.
And then the biological interpretability, that is also very important
for the clinicians to understand why the model is working this way
and which region is adding more information for the
decision-making. And also,
for our model, we are working on prognostic
setting like high-risk and low-risk patient.
But apart from that, if we can add more value to the predictive utility,
like which patient will be benefited from monotherapy, I say monotherapy or
I say chemotherapy, I think these three points would make the
model stronger for prospective validation.
Yeah.
Yeah, I agree with her points also.
So for our case also, we work on head and neck cancer
dataset. So data is very limited for the head and neck
cancer, so we could not
incorporated all the subsite of the head and neck cancer.
So if we have some additional cohorts
consisting of different anatomic sites, so the
generalization of the model could be better.
And the second point is for the
multi-cohort cross-validation.
So we found the spatial cluster, and they are
predictive for the survival and the therapy response, but we could not
validate it on the other multi-cohort institutional
external validation. So we would like to do that.
And in addition to that, there are various
biomarker in immunotherapy, like the PD-L1.
So also we'd like to check how
comparable the result are with those biomarker,
and if we could come up with a
Some idea like how to combine those
existing biomarker, clinical biomarker with the
AI-derived biomarker. And lastly,
as she mentioned, interpretability.
If we can understand
which portion of the
H&E slide or which clusters are more beneficial for
the treatment response, and which are actually giving the
differentiating power to those
biomarker, AI-driven biomarker, that will be useful.
So, yeah.
Wow. I cannot agree more with all as
Sumana already. I just want to echo that. Right.
More importantly, we need more external validation cohort.
Like in our path2Omics-HE, we was able to collect
nine external independent cohort.
But in total, we have only 500
sample. So, and although that was totally
unsupervised approach without any further training,
we assume that it worked very well, but we are
still not very sure it is good enough or strong enough to
bring it to clinical application or not. We are still not sure.
So we need more sample.
Got it. That's very helpful. Do we have any pathologists in the room?
Anyone?
Right there.
Oh, awesome. So maybe this is a question for you.
We've heard from the speakers about what they think they need to do to bring
this to clinical practice. I was just curious if you all had any thoughts around
what
level of evidence would you want to see from these AI approaches?
Not necessarily the ones that represented today, but in general that
you've seen, that you've come across, that you thought were very exciting,
but you were like, "I'm not sure." What is the level of
evidence that you would want to see for you to feel comfortable in
using
AI-based digital pathology solutions in clinic?
Anyone wants to comment on it?
Sorry to put you on the spot.
Thank you for the question. Actually, we work a lot with the digital
pathology and
prediction biomarkers, but I think we're still at the
level of
predicting with the small cohorts as they mentioned.
But what is most important is when you have to sign out a case,
and you have to say that it's going to be predictive, you really need to feel
comfortable on how this is going to be.
As a pathologist, we want to know what is driving the prediction,
but at the same time, we understand that at the end,
we're not going to understand how the AI work, right?
So you need to have clinical evidence that can work in different scenarios.
So that is my perspective. But I think that we're still looking at this,
and I could say that most of pathologists do not feel
very comfortable with
any of these prediction tools in the AI
world. But we're going over there, and at the least, if we
have a reliability, that's going to be a game
changer.
So just so I understand, there were three points that you mentioned.
First is validation, where you have
consistent validation across large studies for you to feel confident.
The second aspect is interpretability, where you need to understand what is driving
the models for you to feel comfortable.
Exactly.
And, there was one more point that you had mentioned about reliability,
right?
Exactly.
You used the word reliability, which I think has more to do with reproducibility
of the results. Is that fair?
Exactly. Reliability, like for example, you know that the H&E changes,
the staining changes from center to other center.
You want to make sure that this is not going to be something that is going to be
driving your samples, like to a high or low risk.
So that is basically it.
That's great.
Mm-hmm.
And those are also very similar guidelines for
FDA approval, so that lines up. Thank you. Thank you for your comments.
All right. Is there anyone? Go ahead.
Hi. Great talks. I also have one question for this on spatial
transcriptomics. So you mentioned about HE-IST and
path2Omics approaches. So since last few years, we see several
approaches that are coming or developing for gene expression
prediction from histology like Estinate, THAI 2 Gene, HE2ST,
or more recent like DeepSpot, SEAL and STPath, several
approaches. So on high level, all of them are extracting
some imaging features from histopathology patches and doing some correlation
analysis with the full transcriptome that were available.
So I want to understand what is core difference or
the major concept behind HE-IST or
path2Omics, and have you compared these models with
other models that are recently developed in literature?
I'd like to start. Yeah.
So yeah, there are several model. So our approach is quite
different. So we want to leverage the deep learning model to predict
the spatial transcriptomic, but use it for the large cohorts.
So specifically, we are
focusing on the large cohort to identify spatial biomarker,
which is not possible with few samples.
So our approach is to transfer-- We have some model and use those
model to capture those spatial biomarker from the large cohort and
apply it to some other external cohorts, so that we can have
some spatial biomarker related to survival and treatment
response.
Okay. And, can I ask like h-What was your cohort
size when you developed these models for H&E to spatial
transcriptomics gene expression prediction?
So yeah. So for head and neck cancer, we use
10 patients. However,
it has around 22,000 spots,
and we have validated on eight patients, which
consists of around 15,000 spots. So we are training the
model on the spot level and predicting the genes
at the spot level. Yeah.
Okay. Just one last follow-up question.
Did you also use the publicly available H1 key or ST image 4K,
those data sets? Because they are around 1,000 to 1,200 H&E to
ST pairs that are available.
So we are
focusing on the head and neck cancer, so those data sets didn't
include head and neck cancer.
Okay.
Yeah. So that's why the sample size is very small.
Okay. Thank you.
If I can make some comments. I'm a thoracic medical oncologist from
MD Anderson.
So
first comment is that,
I think as a diagnostic tool for the digital
pathology, in a way it's already in clinic by
the digitalized imagings, and pathologists doesn't have to leave their home.
They can make diagnosis in their computer.
Regarding this, I guess the further step of a requirement, I
think we're getting there, but still far away yet.
But I think from the research perspective, this is a very, very useful,
valuable tool. I'll give you one example, and Luisa and me, we
collaborated on this national CMAC clinical
trial biomarker discovery. The major issue we're getting is
we just don't have enough tissue for the sequencing for the profiling.
So one example, we got 150
patients. We have only nine patients
has enough samples for exome sequencing, RNA-seq,
multiplex immunofluorescence.
And some have this, haven't had that.
But everybody has digital pathology slides there.
So I think this will give us a much bigger power
to discover certain markers. In the past, we cannot, but now with the
artificial intelligence and machine learning, the machine are able to find some
patterns that human eyes cannot. So I think it's a very valuable research
tool. The second point I want to make is that, and on
Rukmini's study, you can see she showed a combination
of pathomics as well as radiomics.
I think in the future, as a clinician, what I would say is a holistic
view.
Of course, the patient age, gender, all that stuff matters, but
also the radiomics give you a holistic view of whole body,
multiple sites, but in a less granular way.
Pathomics give you very granular information, but only for one
piece, probably 1% of the patient's tissue.
So I think the combination of those two will be eventually needed in the future to
guide the clinicians to select patient for
treatment. The last point I want to make is that, right
now we're using our pathologists as a gold standard.
So the best we can do is as our pathologists tell us,
but in the future, we hope that we can beat them to be better than
pathology. I think the day will come. Thank you very much.
Thank you for your comments.
With that, I think we'll bring this mini symposium to a close.
I'd like to thank all the speakers again for their excellent talks and
being willing to come on stage and give us an impromptu panel.
And of course, I'd like to thank all of you in the audience for being a great
audience. Excellent questions, and of course, fostering the discussion we had.
And on behalf of my co-chair here, Dr.
Tiwari, thank you all for being here. See you next year.
Thank you all.
Any
night
now.